i will start i guess by
introducing both of you i have the honor
of moderating these talks i don't know
what that means
uh for tonight since there's not a whole
lot of moderation that needs to take
place i think
as we continue to grow the panel and
maybe have a third speaker
that'll fall into place a little bit
more but um so i'm andy shaka
and i'm kind of the off-camera moderator
if you need a handout or anything let me
know
i'm also the kind of agent of support
for this um
but our two speakers for those who don't
know and for those who are watching at
home
um are abdu-gaye and greg zadler and
i'll say a little bit about both of you
first
and then i know you'll have comments to
introduce your topics
a little bit more so my immediate right
abner ramon gate abdu for friends
his father did not like it when people
refer to him by this nickname however
and he may go into a little bit about
that
during his own introduction to his work
abdu is originally from mauritania west
africa he lives in kingston
and teaches french in a number of local
colleges uh besides school
responsibilities he is
involved in interfaith projects and
believes that world religions
will have the last word into the
building of a peaceful world
he is married and has two teenage boys
tonight
in this talk he would like to bring the
audience to contemplate ferguson
remembering or reconsidering ferguson
from a historical perspective
asking us to reflect on the notions of
respect equality and justice
through the lenses of a 19th century
african-american woman who used faith as
a powerful weapon
against slavery and women's rights
sojourner truth's speech to the akron
convention will be made available to the
audience
and will serve as the foundation for
tonight's conversation
our other speaker tonight is gregory
sadler
an educator author certified
philosophical counselor and local
kingston resident
familiar to many both through his talks
at the library and elsewhere
and through his popular youtube channel
which we're pleased to say has recently
passed 1.6 million views so
congratulations
his published works to date include one
book and dozens of articles book
chapters and encyclopedia articles
he has been an erasmus institute fellow
a charles chestnut library fellow
a visiting scholar at european graduate
school and has recently been appointed
to the faculty of the global center for
advanced studies
in his teaching public speaking and
popular writing dr salder takes complex
and often difficult texts and thinkers
and makes them accessible for students
lifelong learners and professionals
or to use the motto of his company he
puts philosophy into practice
tonight he will be speaking about a now
classic text in social and political
theory
dr martin luther king junior's letter
from the birmingham jail
so thank you very much thanks yeah
absolutely
anything else that you want to say about
the general idea behind
behind or yeah behind or the evening
yeah i i guess it was uh more
like time table conversation you know
coming together as a friend
um you probably didn't mention it but
andy and i uh met at the culinary where
we both
work that's true and she's only
introduced me to greg
and i think we had one evening around
the table dinner table and
came up with adding something to
this ongoing activities
the philosophy activity how do you call
it
the saturday of saturday event oh yeah
doing something as a supplement i guess
you'd say or
another kind of event this is this is
bigger right what i was saying is that
greg has something going on here and i
do have actual activity
here right i have a monthly islamic
forum that has been going for uh
since april of last year which almost a
year it say so the first wednesday of
every year
every month i hope to have some of my
congregation here because last
last one we had in february
we made an announcement that we're gonna
have this event evening the first time
i didn't send extra
pliers but i hope that they would catch
it from that day
so yeah we we thought about ferguson for
a while
that we should have a conversation
around
and i think uh february has
called black history
and we're hoping to do this with
reconsidering
other you might say
big picture issues um down the line
as a regular thing with the same sort of
format short talks a lot of
community discussion we've talked about
doing a reconsidering charlie
hebdo in the coming months and we're so
we're looking at
a number of other possible topics
to do this process of reconsidering that
think it's
it's great just um to sort of point out
too that this is something that
developed very organically through
conversation
and that's something that's very
important both to greg and i
and to abdul and as you said it was
around a table
um just having a good conversation and
so we're hoping that these events
actually yield good productive
conversation in the same way
um it's it's the community building that
takes place when we
talk about the historical but also the
contemporary and look
for threads of understanding between all
of us that will contribute to this so
i think it goes without saying that your
feedback and your input is encouraged
and welcomed
as we go through these topics yeah we're
hoping that it becomes a community
dialogue
that we reconsider our approaches to
various things um
and that that contributes to sort of the
programming itself
yeah you could say that we're all 11 for
this this kind of thing
yeah so i'm very appreciative that you
guys came out for this
yeah yeah thanks for being here yeah
well should we should we start yeah you
want to go first
we're going to google fest it's up to
you
ask
actually i think i'm just going to pick
up from what you just say or maybe it
was andy but when you say conversation
you know it's uh that's how i wanted to
um present this stock
that is not like in a
teaching environment where there is a
figure that present for 15 or 30 minute
material that is it is uh
well structured and
then people ask questions i see it like
a conversation
where everyone even though we might be
the ones who have
made a little more preparation before
being here
but when the material is is presented
and everyone
is part of the building of
the theme like everybody brings his
his past present
i'm from a tradition that is more oral
african my african background that i
bring here
and it there is uh that
you know very old view that uh
you know life is is more spiritual than
what it
shows yeah we believe more in the
invisible
and then came islam i am from a country
that is called islamic
i don't know if it appears in my face or
not
but mauritania as she mentioned
is an islamic country just like iran
there's only four actually in the world
that have that islamic
adjective added to the
the name of the country the public
islamic mauritania which means you born
islam and you i mean you'd be born a
muslim and you died muslim
but yet i'm married to your christians i
made a little bit difference
i don't know how they review me when i
go back but i don't relate that to
the person i choose i mean uh um
as uh i think everybody here knows the
truth
i'm talking about her hello
this is my good friend chris
chris chris browser hello hi
i mentioned chris i i'm just starting so
you're not you're not late
and believe it or not as i mentioned i
talked about mauritania
this is a fellow american who have
visited my country small world
small world right as a peace corps he
spent
years in mauritania so he can eventually
support the idea that
it is an islamic country and i don't
know how safe it is today to go back
there
as an american or something else than
a muslim it might be the same but uh
pioneering this land today is more
challenging than ever right
because of what's going on around the
islamic world and the world in general
even if you are in america but
to connect this
story of sigil truth i think i will go
back to
that conversation around ferguson
because that's all that we started
i thought i wanted to connect ferguson
to
um the truth and the idea
of just the concept of justice the
concept of
fighting for what you believe
being ready to even die
for what you believe i think
for many ferguson with uh that young man
michael brown
who was killed on that uh terrible night
of
august um 19th was it august 19th
of last year um you know
it was a simple scaffold between a
police
officer and a young man tall
frightening maybe in an external view
uh he was killed at the end of the day
and behind it you know a lot of unrest
before all the celebrations and
i think marches and what happened in new
york
i think before that there was uh you
know
that reality
inside that little place of
missouri what is a call to the city
now focus on it yeah missouri is it is
it missouri
has never been missouri right it became
like a spotlight for the world to know
now what uh misery is about but
but what happened in that uh situation
aftermath
is there were some changes on it or not
i mean it was
it was pain for the family for black
people said that one of us was killed
at the end of the day something has
changed what changed
and now the police agents have to wear a
camera
because if there was a camera maybe
there wouldn't be all this
i would see that yeah what happened what
did it happen
did he attack the policeman
and was killed or was it like brutally
um killed because of his calvin skin
because maybe he's a wild boy because
right before that he was caught
right savaging a peaceful
salesman and then
there was a lot of conversation around
it
so what happened after that in my uh
personal view is it took
uh you know to lose a life no matter
what what was before
for something to happen something good
to happen for the
community to happen for uh maybe the
black people are
fighting for justice he took a life
and then there's more that we can say
about that
is much more we can say about refugees
but what happened before
ferguson why but what connects
the two to me is a very thin
line it's about what is in the heart of
people a conversation
will uh occur and then things change
change will happen
but what is it that will affect
what will actually affect history what
is it that we will retain
from it what is it that will uplift
the people that we are i think that is
the the
lesson that we will come up with
and sojourner truth i mean she
she just uh you know she's a figure that
we cannot forget i i came up to
to her when i was thinking about history
month
and i mean yeah black history month
february
and then i realized actually she's part
of us she's from
ulster and
when i look at her i think i should pass
this on
because this fire in the back
she was born isabella born free
right an african-american woman and a
slave have a nice summary here
of uh you know a snapshot of her
identity
she was a young teenager who was sold to
john
demon his french french probably french
john 17 years later
isabel escaped to demons control and
became a runaway slave
after traveling family to family for two
years she found herself in new york city
the anti-slavery act that was passed
allowed the truth to be free
she was able to sue her former owner for
selling her son
into slavery
it will happen next in into in 1843
isabella joined her name to sojourner
through
and preached in new england about a
woman's right
on slavery later on in her life she
helped
other slaves find freedom and success
in society generally women who were
forced
into slavery at an early age did not
have
any education truth helped the woman
learn how to succeed
in the outside world even though she was
not educated
black woman in society was seen with
little respect
no low social status it looks like even
white women
those days were not as don't know if you
can describe that often
um 20 years after truth moving speech
historian felt the silence
had been broken this is a quotation
silence had been broken
and the veil was raised to reveal the
long
obscured and ignored activism
and experiences of one house of the
black population
in america is that did you catch that
good when historian looked back
on surgical truth speech they realized
she stated
a radical idea for the mid 18th
because she proposed and questioned why
black women
were not treated with the same respect
as a white woman i drew this uh
aunt i a woman
you guys uh i see that before everybody
here nothing looking for
i wanted to ask a woman of the audience
to
read it for us as we
start a certain conversation around
what is called one of the most
red i have
i think it's on this page here
just to read that for you
as she became one of america's most
quoted
most outspoken black woman role models
to reform
her secret she believed her life was in
the care of a higher power
she didn't believe in man made a
limitation and she never looked
she never took no no for an answer
okay and your volunteer for the reading
sure yeah okay so let's let's let's go
through this
ain't i a woman well children
well there is so much racket there must
be something out of kilter
a thing that tweaks the negros of the
south and the women of the north
all talking about rights the white men
will be in a pretty in a fix pretty soon
but what's all this here talking about
that man over there says that women need
to be helped into carriages
and lifted over ditches and have the
best place
everywhere nobody ever helps me into
carriages
or over mud puddles or gives me
any best place and ain't i a woman
look at me look at my arm i could have
plowed
and planted and gathered into barns and
no man
could hate me and ain't i a woman
i could work as much and eat as much as
a man
when i could get it and bear the lash as
well
and ain't i a woman i have borne
13 children and seen them most
all sold off to slavery and when i cried
out with my mother's grief
none but jesus heard me and ain't
i a woman then they talk about this
thing in the head what's this they call
it
intellect somebody whispered that's it
honey
what's that got to do with women's
rights or negroes rights
if my cup won't hold but a pint and
yours holds a court
wouldn't you be mean not to let me have
my little
half measureful then that little man in
black there he says
women can't have as much rights as men
because christ wasn't a woman where did
your christ come from
where did your christ come from from
god and a woman man had
nothing to do with him if the first
woman god
ever made was strong enough to turn the
world
upside down all alone these women
together
ought to be able to turn it back and get
it right side up again
and now they just asked him to do it
the men better let them oblige to you
for hearing me
and now old serger ain't got nothing
more to say
thank you thank you
yeah before uh um you know opening uh
the conversation here i just wanna
imagine what uh
you know this this talk as we introduce
it
it's uh i guess a beginning of
a movement change starts with a small
group
and and it comes from the deepest part
of ourself
right so jiren was described as
you know she was a slave she was like
she was not educated it was like she was
like the last
of the last and
she became a voice she became
personality
she became change to become you know an
authority
and you know she talked about
appearing 15 children a woman
and among them i'm sure you know the you
know
you know the the story that many of them
or at least
four or five were solved
and then the young boy the the youngest
the five-year-old
also was about to be solved and that was
the reason why
and i think it relates the journey to
kingston it was in the kingston court
that she wanted to fight
the situation of that young boy five
years
old just was just gone one day
so she she went through it and she said
to herself
one day i have nothing to lose right
that story about the chariot in in dc
or whatever
so what i'm saying here and i think it
will relate to
uh martin luther king if you relate to
rosa park
it took something in in the in the gut
is that what you call it some somewhere
within us
that cries out and say just die
and i see no difference i mean you may
be against it
but the act of uh of rosa park
uh what uh um
truth has done is not too far from what
michael brown has done
you get beaten you know you are the last
maybe he was lost his son maybe his
parents didn't care much about him he
was stealing he should be a miserable
guy but what do you do with those people
you kill them
you you come to a stage where you say
you know i can be the offering
in the altar like jesus i put them in
the same line
and men rise above
the regular ones who you know got some
time just like no
don't go that far it's dangerous right
that's what we do
then change take time
are you guys following me sometimes my
accent will not make it right too clear
the gentleman over there is like what's
he saying
oh i'm getting what you're saying oh
yeah that's good thank you i'm thinking
i'm comparing it to what's going on in
my own
right right so so i'm being very very uh
expanded in my uh presentation but i
just wanted to challenge you in this uh
dynamic of my introductory
words or because i don't want to do a
speech i just wanted to
rise questions and issues
and maybe contradictions maybe something
that is not
something you hear every day say yeah i
have something to say here
all right so we can go from uh you know
this uh
this text to me that says a lot
this is the spirit of situation
it is a spirit here in these few lines
you said this was a speech i
said wow i like this kind of speech
people usually
you know journals right like one page's
pitch
to me it's a it's full of passion and
spirit
it's similar to um i mean there's a
couple things i was thinking while you
were
while you were talking and one is that
for me the most direct connection to the
ferguson case has been
emmett till perhaps much more than
someone likes to journal truth but i see
i see this connection and i see this
connection in other movements where
other questions were asked i mean i
think of you know
alice walker and her whole work in
search of our mother's gardens and she's
talking about
you know head ragged generals and all of
the children that she could have raised
or what
what you know what was lost because
people who
had something like surgery truth a
question to ask
or an action to take were denied that
ability because of the circumstances of
their birth
and you know when you say was this
uh young man guilty of something perhaps
but didn't warrant
the result that's sort of the connection
because for the longest time i think
people contextualized the emmett till
case
with the idea that he also was kind of a
naughty boy
right um there's contradictory stories
that have been told about it but it was
sort of like did that
even if he was a naughty boy i mean you
know punishment crime
consequences action it's a
disproportionate relationship
and so you know there's that piece of it
but then there's also the piece of
the question being asked here and when
you imbue gender into the argument and
you talk not only about
race i loved your use of that term you
know the last of the last
um the questions keep getting asked
because the last continue to find
themselves last
and whether it's um you know a religious
identity or a
racial one or you know gender
orientation identity
it it's a constant refrain
of people who are not in positions of
power
you know so i really enjoyed the way
that you
phrased that um
yeah thank you it was a nice comment
um yeah jump in and you wanna say
something
well i um have just been reading about
in ferguson i mean it's not as if
uh michael brown was an
incident alone by any means the
circumstances there are
very extremely difficult even
compared to many other places in the
united states
they're extremely difficult they have a
system of a debtor's prison there which
is
just horrifying and
there are so many people who have no
opportunity
to get ahead and it's not just
an opportunity because oh
you could do better there's an actual
system for
for making life extremely
difficult for a class a whole class of
people
it's not just black people it's a class
a lower a whole lower class of people
and when you look at how
hugely that's impacted of a really large
population
and then one outcome this one outcome
that came into the news
was this boy gets killed
with the expected outcome that it
wouldn't mean anything
and nobody would especially care about
it
so yeah or it would all blow over in a
week or something like that
you know there's there's other
communities in that that same area
that um aren't ferguson but
are in just as bad of a
sort of predatory legal position
the state of missouri has actually
brought suit against
a number of them recently ferguson isn't
in the suit because they don't have
enough data
from ferguson yet to put them in it and
it has to do with this this uh the suit
actually has to do with how much of
their
the income for these communities is
coming from
these punitive fines and ticketing
and things like that that make it very
very difficult for
anybody who's who's poor to to
not be even more poor not to fall
further and further behind
yeah town a town in ferguson i
understand was
is run like the supervisor and all the
officials
were white and the majority of people
in ferguson are black i think i'm not
sure and the police department was
mostly white as well
right that's like really a glaring
problem like how did that
come about and i think they were saying
that people are going to be encouraged
now
to vote more yeah the last mayoral
election there was a 12 turnout for the
vote
the mayor is white the police chief is
white the
vast majority of the police are white
the
town board has one one black man on it
and one
white woman and then the rest is all
white men
so there's there's no proportionality
whatsoever
i think your question is interesting too
because you're saying like how did that
happen
i mean people were asking that same
question in jasper texas in 1999
you know um after the dragging behind
the truck when
they said the washington post sent two
totally different racially comprised
news crews down there
and the remarkable things people were
saying when they thought that they were
in company of people who felt the same
way that they felt
and they juxtaposed those and it was you
know i mean it's a fascinating study
about sort of
how in fact those things not only happen
but are reinforced
right right right and once they get that
power then those people want to keep
that power
yeah yeah ferguson used to be
more uh racially mixed
you know 20 years ago oh yeah it's
changed demographically
and actually a lot of those counties in
that area are not counties a lot of
those townships within
st louis county have changed over time
um then become much more segregated you
know
so you can say that part of it is an
inheritance uh even
even then though it wasn't majority
white you know
20 years ago no but it wasn't it wasn't
as
disproportionate but i think one of the
things that disproportionately
the poor yeah are there's a
disproportionate number of
the poor and the
so it's a it's not not the little the
race thing but it's a
there's a class thing that's right
yeah yeah and i think that's that become
actually more
of a reality that you want to look into
because poor and then uneducated
could belong to the 18th century
not to the 21st century but it is the
reality that is so
appalling right yeah and then we have
this
police that is to be
like policing which is more like taking
care of
but it is mainly brutality
you hear more that water than policing
and then helping and assisting right
then when it comes to racial
mix the reality
i mean the hurt become like more
consistent now if we compare what is
happening in
america to what is happening in england
in france
in japan i don't know if you you
try to look outside america and see what
is happening what is dynamic between the
people the community and
yeah yeah what do you see
i i i just went through a study that
says in 2012 according to the fbi
american polices shot and killed 409
people
the sounder now the the british
counterpart
shot and killed no one
the german police the german police
unlike the the brits
are routinely armed shot and killed
eight people
japanese have killed one in the past six
years
you know i think part of the part of the
part of the function of that
is that when we're looking at european
uh countries there are there are
national standards
for policing and there's things across
the board
it makes it very difficult to talk about
you know the police in america because
every single county has its own sheriffs
who may be great or maybe horrible
every township has its own police and
then you add on top of that state
troopers
and federal you know uh policing
agencies
and you have this this uh incredible you
know
motley fabric where policing can be
excellent
in one area and then right down the
street they can just be a bunch of thugs
you know and i just wanted to add a
small point about uh
i read recently in england it's not that
the police
aren't armed they used to be unarmed
they are are now
with some of them but and they do
shoot and they have shot people in the
same
similar situations but they
particularly are taught to and don't
shoot to kill
yeah which is yeah when you read about
people being
being shot you know 15 15-20 times
i mean those stories don't go away you
know we all remember that
i think the other thing too is the
comparisons
to extend to a conversation where i
haven't even pre-talk if you look at the
incarceration statistics they're also
completely unequal
you know i mean it's it's a it's a like
you're saying it's
it's a class and access issue that
underpins a lot of this
and an education issue that underpins a
lot of it
so i think i'll go ahead
well one of those things that struck me
i mean years ago i heard a
statistic about the
the prosecution of
for for police wrongful death
and it's like virtually non-existent
there's no review there's just this
yeah you know you're here to protect us
the police are prosecuting themselves
right
but but the thing that but
the thing that struck me about what you
said about soldier truth
was this um idea that
you know sometimes you have to you know
change happen sometimes you have to
you know sometimes you have to you know
push yourself into the
struggle or stand for the struggle and
all the things that means you know
somebody may you know somebody you know
may shoot you you know as as often
happens you know
um but on the other side of that
there was a time this summer i i thought
after ferguson that there was going to
be
just concentrated light you know a beam
of light
on on these shootings you know people
are going to be more aware but people
are going to say oh
wait you know you know her turn line
here which is you know
you know all that racket there must be
something
out of kilter you know that's there must
be something out of kilter
yeah but what i found
what i found since then is
people just are more and more dug in in
their positions
you know um and
you know the people on on both sides
like well
you know i'm gonna die for this yeah and
and it goes to it goes to isa or the
islamic state um
it it goes for you know it's like
you know cat you know
can't we just say you know hey
i'm a woman too or i'm born a woman or
you know
let's take a breath you know instead of
how do we how do we how are we
how do we become better listeners how do
we become more empathetic how do we
anticipate you know why is isis so out
of kilter that they
want to go around chopping people's
heads off you know
um so i don't have the answers to that
but that's the question that your
corporate your
your statement wrote right
that's what stands out in my mind yeah i
think you're making such a good point
that people
would hope that it would be an
integrating
like there'd be something that would
bring people together afterwards and
instead what we often see is an
immediate
response that's you know aghast or lots
of loud voices
and then it becomes more and more
polarizing and it's as if each new
dialogue creates greater space between
us instead of closing that space
um yeah because we don't have a common
language and oftentimes that makes it
very difficult yeah we don't have common
experience
and you know i think part of what that
takes
is um we have a lot
we have a very balkanized uh national
community
where you know you've got conservatives
over here and liberals over here or
you've got you know this over here and
that over here it can be
split any any number of ways and
two things that really sort of struck me
i saw these a long time ago but i also
over the last few days was looking at
some of these
one was a video and there was a woman
who was
involved in the protest early on and she
was
um she was you know she had her back to
the police
she was actually haranguing the crowd
and
the reason she was doing that was she
said look these guys are
they're they're you know they're already
bad we know that but
the rest of you you know and she was
talking about
how um if they didn't want their their
children to be
subject to these bad guys over here we
already know
are you know brutal um then we'd better
make sure that they're not
you know slipping out and doing this and
doing this
and that's on these guys and what she
was doing is she's talking to her
community and trying to hold them to a
standard
i also saw a great piece and i forget
exactly where it was
but it was in a conservative website
and it was one of these op-ed pieces and
it was saying conservatives really ought
to be very concerned about what's going
on in ferguson instead of lining up
behind
the police and lining up behind the
authorities
because what's happening in ferguson is
a
prime example of a terrible local
community for some of the you know
reasons that we're going to discuss
about debtors prisons and
that sort of stuff and the word that was
used is predatory uh governments
local governments are quite often more
and more predatory
and usually conservatives have this
great line about you know local
governments are where we want to be and
you know
the big government should get out of
things
but if if you know what this was a
conservative author talking to
conservatives saying look if
you want your project to fly you need to
actually
make sure that you're you're paying
attention to injustice when it's taking
place and not sweeping it under the rug
but i think that the general lesson that
we could draw from that
is that if there's going to if you know
sunlight is going to be the antiseptic
that we want it to be
you know transparency and all that the
second step that has to happen
is people in all these different
communities actually holding their
communities
to some sort of standards rather than
giving them a pass
and saying well those other guys over
there are bad so we can do whatever we
want
and that fits in perfectly with what you
know martin luther king was always
saying
non-violent action requires that you
hold yourself to higher standards
than the the jerks who are are
oppressing you
and a lot of times like it's you know
there's certain there's certain groups
that you can say well they're always
going to do that but none of them are
irredeemable
i mean we're from uh wisconsin and so
there was a recent thing with the
milwaukee police chief
after after all the ferguson stuff um
and the uh
you know the the the new york stuff as
well
where um you know the statistics in the
city of milwaukee which is still a very
segregated city
are that you know you know
crime in the black community takes an
incredible toll
on black people um and he was being
criticized
at a press conference because he was
talking on a cell phone
while somebody was you know trying to
protest and talk about you know ferguson
in milwaukee
and he said i'm on the phone with
somebody whose daughter was just shot
a five-year-old girl and now we're gonna
have to go out and try to find the
suspects for this
you know this is the stuff that actually
matters in this community
a bit more than the protest movement
that's going on
and you know that particular police
chief he is a good example of
cops who pulled cops to standards
obviously that's not happening in
ferguson
still today and many other communities
but you can only you can only
affect some sort of change when you get
agents within those particular
communities saying
yeah we have been a bunch of jerks you
know we need to fix this
uh we need to actually hold ourselves to
the standards that human beings ought to
not not just people who are in a sort of
war zone enemy
uh kind of mentality and it's it's tough
to
you know i mean i can do that for for
the communities that i'm involved in you
can do that for the communities you're
involved in but i can't do that for
yours
and you can't do that for mine so it's
not like we can prescribe it
across the board but i think that that's
one of the elements
unless that sort of thing happens we're
not going to see a lot of lasting change
you wanted to say something yeah so i
was thinking about just policing in
general and
we're a country of immigrants and so
policing started
i know judy and i are talking about the
irish i mean so
everybody hated everybody the irishman
totally hated
and and the gangs and the police and i
think
policing was about social control
and about guilty pleas are about social
control about
getting them off the streets and putting
them in putting you know
keeping people down i think policing is
about keeping people down and
i think you need to look at the history
of policing
rather than just say okay you know we're
living now and this is policing but
policing started in this country as
policing the immigrants i really think
that's important that
that's underlying
the xenophobia and you know
just the people in power wanting to keep
the power and keep the money and keep
the capital and keep other people down
and
i don't know it's complicated very
it's very complicated i think that the
theme too is something that's been
touched on is just the
inequity in our education system
you know across the country where well
yeah
i'm a product of public schools
you know for for better or worse but
sometimes when i see
statistics of of what's going on in a
school in
mississippi
you know as a middle-class you know
citizen of peace and i i just
extrapolate all of my experiences onto
the vast america
and it's just not you know i mean i was
just
knocked over when i thought oh my god
there's you know
there's zero education going on here you
know
where where is that potential you know
where is that possibility where
where where is a you know a trail for
hope or whatever and
you know certainly you know certainly
certainly you know when soldier truth
brings her heart to it i mean
that you can't ask everybody
you know she's a remarkable person um
unfortunately you know
not many of us have had that kind of
strength
also maybe that's why america is
different education in france and
england and japan is
probably a lot better and they're not
such a mixed society
i mean france it's a bit different
because things are very
centralized and there's a very very
strong class
system in france and so
you know if you if you want to advance
you have to go to paris essentially
because the parisians run just about
everything the people in the provinces
hate that and then you add on to that
the you know the
failure to to adequately assimilate
all the arab immigrants
you know over several generations now
and there's a lot there's i mean
in general it you could say in general
across the board there's more
standardization
and the school systems are better
there's less cracks to fall through
but they're still there and you know the
suburbs are our slums
you know for many of the large french
cities
and they have a lot of the same sort of
problems that we do and they they go
through some of the same kind of riots
you remember several years back
you know the riots in france and and
there's less economic opportunity there
you know we have so many more people in
prison in this country oh yeah
what's that about i think that's social
control
i think that's a a great sort of segue
into
the next topic just to be sensitive to
time we're nearing an hour
and i think you don't have one of the
handouts
yeah i did somebody yeah i was going to
just offer
a conclusion from these comments about
uh yeah the voices
that uh rose when michael
brown was killed you see people come on
the studio and say i'm michael brown
yeah people say i'm charlie even
president of france maybe uh the vice
president here i don't know who it was
bibi they call him from israel all those
speakers say
i am so what what it takes for
you you say if there was many people
like seasonal truth
actually people are trying to emulate to
those
victims who died for what for what they
believe they wouldn't they didn't have
any fear
i think that's what she was teaching you
know when she hid
after that that mob came to want to
destroy the tent when they were having
that celebration
she said a voice told her why are you
hiding
and she said she just got distracted
from there she came out and said
i'm a child of god i'm the daughter of
god
why am i going to hide and she came out
with power
to to face a enemy who could kill her
right
yeah so i think that's what it takes for
all of us to have that voice in us that
comes out when
you should be running to preserve your
life which is
the natural way to do right but when you
have that courage to come out
in front of the the killer the enemy
it's like you will not die do you think
that
you think that the identification that
goes on with people
doing the you know hands up don't shoot
right right i can't breathe
or i am charlie hebdo i i i my reaction
that is
is quite different um that a lot of it
is just sort of
people latching on to it and doing
something that's very
easy for them that's not really
transforming
too much of close yeah but i suppose
i suppose in some ways it you know it
could if somebody if that's a way
for that way it should lead actually
it's just like a test it's just like a
smoke
yeah right but you say just
this is what they should be actually
those people but what does it mean to
mean them
to be them to emulate them maybe that's
what
they just like about right going up the
street it's about uh
embodying that philosophy yeah
yeah it's about it is about that that
that
culture today of of mind and body unity
either it
is through reiki or through meditation
or other religious one we just wanna
having a unified idea right
yeah yeah that would be a great topic
future talk actually you know
reconsidering identity
and what it means i mean i think we
could do a lot with that
right yeah yeah so let's move on to the
next step
so so i'm going to talk about the letter
from a birmingham jail
and what it has to tell us for ferguson
but i'm not going to focus on
all of the latter um i'm focused on
a distinction that that king makes
in the ladder that i think is very
important and
very relevant here and i'm going to do
basically
five five things and i'm going to go
through it fairly quickly um
one is i want to say a few things about
the the letter itself as as
as a document and then i want to talk
about this distinction
the classic conception of just an unjust
laws
and then look at king's re-articulation
of this that's his real contribution on
that
and then he gives us these three really
important clarifications about it
um and then bring it back to ferguson
and talk about
how you know in what modes i mean it's
easy to say
there's unjust laws the the question is
precisely how what in them makes them
unjust that gives us handles that we can
actually
grip onto that with and so i think king
is really helpful for this
so a few remarks about about the letter
and i think so this may be a surprise to
some of you as it was to me
because we're all of a certain age and
generations this used to be you know
standard reading
in in high schools and colleges
and i think probably a lot of us read
the letter from a birmingham jail
in one of those places in a class
somewhere i was very surprised to find
out
from my my current crop of students that
none of them had ever read it that they
had heard about it they knew it was a
really important document but it was one
of those sort of things where it's
you know um put on the shelf
and it might be a you know a little
multiple choice
question in history test or something
like that or they bring it up
it's a little blurb on a black history
month flyer
but unless they actually read it they're
not going to get anything out of it
it's a really you know brilliant
document
um like a lot of classic texts
this is why we still keep teaching it
it's one that you can go to over and
over and over again and get more and
more
out of i just taught it again this last
term
and you know i've been reading this
thing for for
a couple decades and i still get more
out of it because
it's it's so rich and it wasn't meant to
be a long detailed systematic treatise
he actually wrote it on the margins of
newspapers that were smuggled out of the
jail
so the the document itself kind of
attests to the coherence
of king's thought and way of life but
not just his
the people that he was connected with as
well because they're the ones who
actually put that jigsaw puzzle back
together
you know they had to figure out which
lines are supposed to go
where and so they had to all have
developed a kind of mentality about this
so um there's this classic conception of
just and unjust laws that that predates
king and that he's he's um using
to uh situate his own thinking about
this
and in order for this kind of
distinction to make any sense you have
to acknowledge a few things that i think
we all
want to so in any given place or time
there isn't a perfect coincidence
between the legal and the moral you know
so what's legally prohibited
might not be morally wrong in some cases
or
it might even be morally right or
praiseworthy
or required so if we want to say
there's a difference between morality
and legality
then one of the things that we have to
be able to do is figure out
some sort of standard or criterion for
determining what laws really
are just that is what laws enact and
embody justice
and which ones aren't and so when you
think about
and i this is something i have my
students go through quite a bit when we
talk about this
if you think about what kind of criteria
could work it can't just be personal
feeling
it can't be even just an appeal to
conscience because conscience can be
poorly formed people talk about all
sorts of things as being conscience that
you know it's strictly speaking probably
aren't
uh it can't just be that it aligns with
you know the needs of a particular
power group or you know what happens to
be popular at the time those are those
aren't
very good criteria for that either we've
seen all sorts of problems with that in
history
um so the idea that runs through this
and it's a very ancient idea
is that there's some sort of general
norms something deeper
that we can use to measure or make
judgments about human laws
an interesting example from from the
bible about this that thomas aquinas
actually discusses
aquinas is one of the people king is
going to reference
is this um this uh passage in leviticus
which says
respect not the person of the poor nor
honor the countenance of the mighty but
judge your neighbor according to justice
and you know you think there'd be more
need to talk about don't take bribes
from the rich people don't let them you
know
influence you there probably is more
need for that frankly
but notice what else that has in there
it's saying don't let the fact that you
feel sorry for the poor guy
influence you away from justice either
you're supposed to be
if you're a judge that's why it's a
judicial precept you're supposed to be
actually be
following the norm
you're not supposed to you know be
engaging in preference that's that's an
example of a norm right there
a norm that governs how laws are used
um now laws are what provide us with
order in society
they make it possible to realize certain
common goods
that's another thing that aquinas talked
about
um so we we want to pause sometimes and
think about
when people talk about the law
what what it actually means it's not
just the written codes
it also includes the entire apparatus
like we were talking about before with
policing
with the criminal justice system that's
all part of the law
and we can talk about that as being just
or unjust just as much as the legal code
itself and now laws are subject to being
poorly made
or enforced bias hasty judgment
lack of information ill will that's been
built up for a while
advantage of the stronger handicapping
the weaker even cops having a bad day or
you know like hitting their point of
frustration after a 14-hour shift or
something like that that can lead to
to bad enforcement of the law
same thing can happen with making laws
you know
if uh laws are made hastily oftentimes
they're not particularly good laws
so king brings up two great western
christian thinkers
in the letter from the birmingham jail
one of them is saint
augustine and one of them is thomas
aquinas saint thomas aquinas
on the saint him magazine right
and augustine said and he wasn't you
know this is not an unusual thing back
then
um but they were struggling with some of
the same issues he said
unjust laws are not really laws
there they have the appearance of laws
but they're not really laws they don't
have
they they don't compel um you know
our our compliance in a moral sense
you can compel somebody's compliance by
beating the you know beating them up
or scaring them but that's not the same
thing as actually being able to say you
should obey this
um now thomas and this is some of the
stuff on the handout that i
have given you there thomas actually
gives some more
detailed criteria for that he says just
laws have to be in accordance
with or harmonize with what he calls
eternal law which is really
god god's plan for things
or if we get a little bit closer to us
stuff that we can relate to easier
what he called natural law and you can
think of natural
king uses natural law and moral law more
or less as synonyms
and that's a lot of what's going on and
thomas's idea that the idea is that
there's certain basic norms
that go that go for everywhere no matter
what society we're talking about
and they may not be respected in that
society but
you can determine those by by using
reason to to you know figure these out
and they're very general
when we get down to particulars that's
when things get very messy
but those particulars are measured by
those general principles
so here's what king does that's that's
really extraordinary
he um he has this formula
any law that uplifts human personality
is just
any law that degrades human personality
is unjust
that's the way that he parses being in
accordance with the moral law
and he doesn't mean personality in the
sense of like you know that person's got
a nice personality
or you know somebody being a radio
personality
it means personhood the status of being
a human being and being
being having dignity you know being able
to develop um
all those sorts of things so anything
that uplifts human personality
it's a just law if it degrades it or
deforms it it's bad so he gives it
here's a just a quote from it he says
all segregation statutes are unjust
why because segregation distorts the
soul and damages the personality
how so he goes on he says it gives the
segregator a false sense of superiority
and the segregated a false sense of
inferiority
and then he goes on and uses martin
woodburn he says
segregation to use boober's terminology
substitutes and i
it relationship for the i thou
relationship and
ends up relegating persons to the status
of things
so segregation is not only politically
economically and sociologically unsound
it's a
sort of prudential thing he says it's
morally wrong and it's awful
unjust laws when we realize that they're
unjust laws we should have a
reaction of repugnance to them
um they they they you know a reaction of
disgust
in some ways is appropriate another
example that he could have used but
doesn't
and that would be lynch law you know
lynching of african americans was used
as a mode of what we now actually
recognize as domestic terrorism
but it was also used as is like a
judicial system
and not only of african americans lynch
law was also used you know out in the
west as
as a judicial means as well
but if we look at that we could identify
that as
unjust law as not being you know in
accordance with
the norms that we're looking for now
king then
has these three really important
clarifications that he gets
and i think that these are really
relevant to ferguson
he says an unjust law is a code that a
numerical or power majority group
compels a minority group to obey but
does not make
binding on itself
this is difference made legal so we
think about
what the city council what the
police are doing in ferguson and the
fact that
none of it applies to them but it all
applies to
the residents he says by the same token
a just code is a code that a majority
compels a minority to
follow and that it's willing to follow
itself this is sameness made legal so if
they want to say you can't kill people
they don't get to kill people and if
they were doing that they would be they
would be
it would be just law you can say look
nobody gets to kill anybody and you can
even say
nobody gets to kill anybody but the
state still gets to kill you if you do
it
and that could still be just but if it's
being applied on some group
and the people who are doing it are not
applying to themselves they're not
holding themselves to that standard
then it's unjust another one that he
says that
pertains to democratic societies which
we're supposed to be living in right
is a law is unjust if it's inflicted on
a minority that as a result of being
denied the right to vote had no part in
enacting or devising the law
so we can think about whether you know
unrepresentative representatives
fall into that category the third one
which is really relevant
he says that a law may be just on its
face
but unjust in its application so
now a lot of the things that the the
ferguson community has on the books are
manifestly unjust laws but let's say
some of them were
actually just like you know laws
regulating
you know whether you can steal whether
you can kill all those sorts of things
the law itself can be just but if the
people who are executing the law
the police officers the um
you know the judges the the prison
guards are
are applying it wrongly that can become
unjust and i think that's part of what
we see going on
with ferguson so when we when we think
about ferguson and
when i was sort of plotting this out
there's really like six different issues
that we could disentangle one of them is
the shooting of of
uh michael brown by officer darren
wilson and that was just sort of you
know the tip of the iceberg kind of
thing
a lot of people just wanted to focus on
that not talk about the bigger
stuff as if somehow resolving that case
would fix everything
the situation of ferguson and other
saint louis suburbs over the last 10
10 to 15 years is a different topic
but one that's i think more important to
look at
we can also talk about the protests the
civil disorder the riots and the police
actions and we can talk about what was
right or what was wrong in those
we can talk about the policing you know
slash
prison slash industrial complex which
falls very heavily in this country on
the poor
and minorities as another issue we can
talk about racism itself
as a general issue some people wanted to
focus just on police militarization
um and that that's probably
a mistaken strategy because the sixth
issue
that i think is is probably the most
important in many respects
is um predatory
and and policing and the money mode of
that that lies behind them
that we're going to see so i'm only
going to talk about
the first two there's the second and the
sixth but we can go into all the rest if
you want to
what i want to say about the second is
ferguson is a failed community
in many respects a community is supposed
to be
an association that serves some sort of
common good
and not just a good that like everybody
gets a little share in but
it's supposed to be a place where people
can develop
ferguson is clearly at antipodes
from that now we've talked a little bit
about why that is there's a lot of
poverty a lot of joblessness one of the
things that's been
talked about a little bit lately is um
the the role that the foreclosure crisis
played
in ferguson and these other communities
as well
homes that went through foreclosure
during the crisis from
2007 roughly to to
well really still the present were
bought up by
these big financial entities and
many of the people in ferguson are
renting their their homes or their
apartments from them
and we we know that there's a lot of
racism
still built into the credit system that
people of color
have have trouble compared to white
borrowers with the same credit getting
the same mortgages
and there's sort of cumulative effects
that that happen
because of that it's easier for them to
go into foreclosure
because of that we talked about
representation
already clearly that's a city you know
when you have a 12
turnout rate for a mayoral election
that's a community where people feel
that they don't have any sort of stake
now why why is that the case that's the
sort of the sixth
issue this predatory government
um and when i when i sort of thought
about what are the key elements of this
um there's there's we can talk about
specifics like the debtor prisons
but there's three general features one
is this regime
of just criminalizing things that the
population is going to be doing
and you know some of these it's not
necessarily whether you have a law
against say driving without insurance
but you can talk about how that's
actually enforced
and how much of a burden falls on people
because of it
there's ways to enforce laws where it's
not you know
really wrecking somebody's life and
there's ways of enforcing it where
where it does and why is that about
unjust and unjust laws
it's not just that there's not equity
they're not being treated as people
um because of that they're being sort of
put into the class
of criminals um there's this displacing
the costs
of of law and order onto the community
at large
that's going on as well one of the one
of the things that this predatory um
government in ferguson is doing is
charging the people who
actually wind up in court exorbitant
fees
and issuing warrants if they don't pay
them
uh and then you know putting them back
into you know into jail
there there's actually more warrants out
uh in ferguson than there are people
i honestly got now some of those could
be for people from other
municipalities but you know there's 20
something thousand
people in ferguson there's something
like 30 000 warrants
currently out
the other thing is that there's this
sort of cascade effect
of added or multiplied what i'm calling
subjugations
of the people once you're in the system
you're you become extremely vulnerable
to
all sorts of uh added indignities
and again this goes back to the do these
laws degrade
personality i think that they very
clearly do king would say
these are they're not segregation laws
but they're something that's
pretty much as bad as segregation laws
so here's just a few of the things that
are going on there are
fines for missed court appearances and
track
traffic tickets and also the late fees
tacked on to later unpaid fines
those are the the city's second largest
source of revenue
so that's a city whose um
business plan whose business model is
based on taxing people
through criminal through you know making
them into criminals
there's actually a plan on the books to
increase ticketing
in 2015. um the revenue from violations
which
represents um you know in
in this last year was 11.8 percent
of the city's you know take um they want
to raise it to 15.7
so the so the mayor and the city council
are telling the cops
you need to enforce more tickets um
that's adding to to the tension there in
um uh
you know policing we you know they've
done some studies on this they know that
the
racial profiling is going on pretty
routinely
a lot more traffic stops for black
residents per capita than there are for
white residents
interestingly drugs and you know arms
and things like that are getting found
more often in the white busts um we'll
call them
and in the black bus
about half of the courts in st
louis county engage in practices of
charging high
court fines and fees on non-violent
offenses and then arresting people when
they can't pay so it isn't just ferguson
and if they fixed ferguson there would
still be the same kind of
community rot going on next door
as well ferguson just happens to be one
of the particularly bad ones
if you can't pay all the fines at once
they put you on an installment plan
and that means that you actually have to
physically come to the court
once a month and pay a certain amount or
explain why you haven't paid
courts often start proceedings before
their their time when they're supposed
to happen and lock the doors
so that defendants showing up on time
can't get in and therefore can be
charged the 150
250 dollars whatever it is particular
fine
on top of everything else that they're
getting courts also unconstitutionally
close the courts to non-defendants
so for people who have children they're
not allowed to bring their children into
the court to handle their
their case and this is a good example of
you know
how these these things fit into each
other
there are people whose kids have been
taken away
by child protective services because
you know they have to be in court they
would leave their kids in the parking
lot
or with somebody else or in one of the
city parks
you know cps would come by and now
they've got a whole new set of problems
and there's there's the whole gutter
prism thing when we talk about debtors
prisons
people who can't pay they get a warrant
out for their arrest
they're brought into the prison while
they're in the prison they're running up
a bigger bill
because they're charged for everything
within the prison
those who are stuck in in it's not is
there dead or jails is really because
it's the county thing
or the the city um but one of the things
that that that
also affects that courts don't don't
meet that
that often there and so
depending on what you're arrested for
you might actually be
in jail even if you've you know you're
not
in there for for not paying fines or
something like that you might be in
there for several weeks before you even
go to trial
so you you look at all of these
different things these are just a few
examples of the stuff that's going on
and has been going on in ferguson for a
very long time
um and getting worse and worse even
after the
the shooting even after the protests um
what's what's going on there from king's
perspective you have a dehumanization
of an entire class of people they are
being treated
as um as things as
essentially revenue generators
um that's their only value you know it's
it's almost
like you know the exact opposite of what
a community is supposed to be
leadership and policing within a
community is at least in theory supposed
to be supporting the common good
there is no sense of a common good there
and it doesn't really make sense to
fault the residents for that
when the people who are sending you know
the clear message
barely let some of the residents have
time to uh to think about anything
because they're you know they're
constantly trying to
pay off these fines a lot of people have
you know lost their jobs by being in
jails there
so it becomes extremely difficult to get
out of it and you wind up in this kind
of
essentially debt slavery that
shouldn't be happening so in some
respects
you know there isn't official
segregation there that battle was fought
in the south and you know those sort of
things are allowed
but this amounts to a re-segregation
um of things and so it's it's a very
unjust legal regime in many respects
and you know all different parts of it
would have to be changed in order to
make it just
um so that's that's you know what i
think king has to to contribute to
thinking about
about this and these are things that we
can get out of the letter from the
birmingham jail we see how relevant it
is
today to today's problems as well
one thing i'll say just to sort of kick
off conversation
and fulfill my duty as moderator
is uh you know you mentioned that
students aren't being taught
the letter and i've
taught for years a class that normally
had the letter and that would be sort of
like a
freshman composition course or you know
an introductory to humanities course or
things like that
both for state university new york city
university new york you know private
colleges
um in all of the primers that like
you know the bedford reader or any of
these books that typically get used in
those courses
that letter was replaced with one of two
essays
one would be david foster wallace's this
is water his commencement speech to
georgetown
inspiring students kind of question
authority um
and the second was the last lecture by
randy pouch
and so for whatever reason the editors
seem to think that that kind of like
inspirational motivational you know be
yourself
message was the one to replace king's
absolute questioning it's like a perfect
consumerist
exactly and i just thought you might
find that interesting because
you know it's to me it's fascinating
that those are seen as interchangeable
i didn't know that they'd been replaced
i mean i i see a lot of readers where
it's still
in there it's just nobody teaches it
yeah
the letter from a birmingham jail was uh
63.
um
well what was the randy pouch piece the
last lecture
the one he delivered at carnegie mellon
so they're both collegiate
you know sort of one commencement speech
by david foster wallace which is a
satire and as
yeah i mean it's you know it says it's
like swiftian
in the way that it's you know talking
about the the future that they have
ahead of them
um to buy the biggest cars they can and
all that kind of thing and
you know that's what he was known for
david foster waltz but
yeah nothing wrong with that sort of
stuff no but it should be i mean
king's letter really ought to be part of
our
national curriculum yeah i mean i found
that it was like that when i would teach
in
you know in cuny schools and many of the
students had come up through the regions
they had no knowledge of who emmett till
even was they'd never even heard about
him
rosa parks i mean the their conception
of who she was
was all over the place you know um
there's a real sense of
sort of a historical you know missing
right and so yeah yeah but i thought you
might find that kind of interesting
i mean that's the sort of issue too how
can we
those of us who are you know like 40 on
up
how can we what can we do to make sure
that this stuff
actually does get to the present
generation
of kids who aren't going to be getting
in schools because clearly the schools
aren't interested in in teaching these
things anymore
you know yeah it's i mean it's all over
our culture it's kind of like that whole
twitter feed i'm sure that
you know you've encountered that notion
of the people who are saying that kanye
west was going to make paul mccartney a
big star
it was like there was a whole article on
it because they did a song together and
people were like isn't that great kanye
west is
you know brought this totally unknown
singer paul mccartney so for us
that seems like crazy because we find it
so funny yeah but they're serious it's
like you know he's gonna blow up like
paul mccartney is gonna you know i don't
know who this guy is
they have frame shots of it like in the
guardian the atlantic i mean people were
talking about it beyond the music scene
yeah you know that's pretty fun yeah
to get back to ferguson what's amazing
is i mean
those those are glaring
you know the the this society the
culture this
the you know that you
you describe them just you know it just
seems unbelievable but
you know right here in new york state
you know you go through the criminal
justice system you're disenfranchised
you know you
lose your right to vote i don't know
what i mean it's different from every
state
but you you you your
it impinges on your credit report which
then impinges
you've already got a problem finding a
job and then all of a sudden you've got
knocks on your credit
reporting then it becomes more you know
more and more you know difficult to get
that
minimum wage job flipping yeah mopping
the
mopping the floor you know you know yeah
and you know so so so you know that so
we don't you know new york state doesn't
have those onerous
conditions that they have in missouri
but there's
it's still you know you know kingwood
flag that is um
yeah unjust uncivil um
you know and with this it's partly
because so much has been left up to
local communities to get away with this
kind of stuff you know
at least in missouri now they're
cracking down at the state level on some
of this
this this stuff but i heard a commentary
that came to mind when you said the
false sense of superiority
a commentary on the
talking about the police system in new
york city
and there was a certain sense of outrage
from the police because they have been
treated like such
tremendous heroes ever since 9 11
and they were able to use that
to gain a sense in themselves of
superiority
where they could do no wrong they were
you know thanked and
as they walked down the street and they
got like dates and i mean
you know they got tremendous value out
of
out of their bravery and now they're not
getting that
anymore i mean that's kind of in the
past
and now suddenly they're not only are
they not
getting that expectation but they're
they're getting
flagged for you know misbehavior and
that just added to that sense of
superiority yeah and you know king is
not against
a sense of superiority in general if you
actually have something to be
superior about like when you know i have
a dream speech he says
um i i want a i want a place where my my
children are not going to be judged on
the color of their skin
but the content of their character
they're going to be judged so if they're
a bunch of scumbags
call them scumbags you know that's fine
just don't call them scumbags because
because they're black or white or
whatever because that's irrelevant but
if they behave like that
so king would say you know like somebody
who i don't know say
deservedly won a nobel peace prize
because that's been
that one's been you know kind of thrown
in it doesn't mean anything these days
you know i mean anybody can get it
it seems uh you know
if there's the nobel prize people like
him
um you know but if it means something
if there's a there's a real criteria in
there it's okay to be superior about it
but there are so many
things where people um
assume a superiority for
arbitrary reasons for for the wrong
reasons for for things that don't have
anything to do with whether they're
a good person or not you know i think
the police to go back to that particular
thing
they really screwed themselves on doing
that work shut down
you know because what they what they
showed is that they are not
that that needed well in new york city
aren't
the police responsible for things like
parking tickets so they're
are there they're responsible for
generating
revenue in a very low low level
which yeah okay it's not as bad as
ferguson but that's most places i think
where the police department is
i don't know if it is most places but i
wonder if if that's just the best
system to begin with when you stop
and think about it yeah you won't you
it's there's sometimes a parking place
right or like a parking authority but um
a lot of what you're saying is that the
the violations
in in the five boroughs are very
different so
you can burrow to burrow yeah and it's
the same thing i used to be a building
super when i was in first in graduate
school
and some i mean you know the amount of
of
may as well have been in debtors jail i
mean you know for building super who
already is not somebody who's
had a ton of money to begin with right
that's kind of nobody
says oh i think i'd love to be a super
you know i'd love to take out the trash
and sort the recyclables and
why don't i do it in an area where you
know drug use is rampant and
you know i'm gonna dig through some
needles and figure out what i can find
so
you know it's i mean it's a dangerous
hazardous job and
you can get fined for every little thing
you know litter on the morning of the
trash pickup
that you had no control over you know is
is two inches from the curb it's a fine
it's a fine it's a fine it's a fine but
it's all going into the same revenue
pool to your earlier point
and so communities come to depend too
on a certain absolutely of um
of fines and tariffs and whatever you
want to call them coming through
so there's a real incentive to make sure
that that you know but how short-sighted
is that
when you think you know if
if you're you're bringing your community
down
if there were a sense of bringing the
community up
these same people who are going to
debtors prison for not carrying
insurance on their car
renters they may eventually be able to
own a house and they'd be paying
property taxes which would have left
a lot more than parking violations yeah
it is it is very short-sighted but i
think that part of it is that they're
not just
engaged in bad prudential reasoning
they have come to see people as
something other than people as just
those
scum or um
you know dollar signs you know it's how
we use
language i mean
you know
new york city has some compared to what
i've seen in detroit
has some fantastic public housing i mean
it might not be for everybody but
i used to walk my dog through these
places
there was lawns there was there was
there were they were
nice communities but they hear people
talk about them it was always in the
most pejorative demeaning degrading
dehumanizing way you know oh you're from
the projects
of this so that and and
just the word the projects is
you know it's not the n-word but it's
stepping close to it and yes as the
language that we've developed since 9 11
where you know
terrorism you know and our our
friend obama you know talks about the
terrorism of years years before but we
we just think of terrorism we think of
you know one specific group you know
we're
you know yeah that's why seeks end up
still getting beat up
right even though they've got zero
connections
yeah yeah so i'm just saying we have to
be
you know we have to be very you know we
have to be we have to be
mindful um
yeah one sort of silly question isn't
the whole human race
rather schizophrenic everybody
educated non-educated first of all
i don't know where i heard this in a
lecture or a movie
there's no such thing as race why do
people still talk about race
yeah is there race there's no race
it's not yellow chinese black people
white people red people green people
whatever
because only humans as far as i know
what about rich and poor is that real
that's just true that's the real race
the class i mean one of the reasons why
we do still have to talk about race it's
one of those chicken egg things
because other people still use race as
uh you know a defining factor
we're stuck with it you know you think
about like how
arbitrary our conception of race here is
that we use for our census categories
um and that it doesn't map on to
conception
you mean to be impaled through the heart
no i mean that's what it feels like
what i mean that practically speaking
you know it's it's not as if we're not
going to be talking about race
30 years from now because there's still
going to be people making decisions
based on you know qualifications of
grace but
part of their but they're schizophrenic
politically intellectually
morally yeah but i don't know
history well that yeah that may be
fine but i i don't know um
well it goes to your earlier point about
the conversation and using conversation
and experience
i feel like to bring things together by
the way there's a new statue of
general truth in toward you and it's
beautiful
yeah it's right on iw yeah
we have about well we have as we i mean
7 30 today we should actually start
wrapping up
yeah um so i was in
i was in grand central station a few
weeks ago when they had
um one of the larger
um i can't breathe protest movements
i was i was there literally at the bar
waiting for a train like i
i wasn't there and the protesters came
in and it was interesting like i
consider myself
a an educated white
male i consider myself on
more liberal than not liberal i consider
myself
more educated on social justice issues
than not
and i have to admit i had no desire
whatsoever to run down and
join that protest movement
and you know you mentioned about how
well it's easy to
have a sign or a t-shirt or something
like that and
and it is easy and it's also easy for me
to kind of uh
clothe myself in the hey i'm trying to
live a good life
you know i i work as an educator and i
try hard to educate
i actively try to educate young men and
women
of all
diversity groups however rich poor black
white brown
however you want to lay that out and i
kind of clothe myself in that
and i can go to sleep at night and i and
i feel like
i feel like i don't have to join that
protest movement
yeah because i'm making my own choices
and what i'm wondering about is
is what's do you there's something
mythological about somebody like
sojourner truth
or martin luther king jr where you have
an
individual a person
that can rally people not a movement
that can rally people but a
person that represents a movement that
rallies people
and and i don't know that we have
that i don't think that barack obama is
that person or do i think he should set
himself up to be that person
so do we when we talk about social
justice today
where is our mythological hero and then
to add another piece of this and
and i do you might speak on more on this
than i can we had
you know in the last two years we had an
incredible international
uprising sometimes lumped together as
the arab spring where a lot of different
countries in north africa and the middle
east
saw tremendous changes
and to my knowledge it didn't seem
anyway reading the paper as i did like
there was in each of those countries
a figurehead a person that represented
that change it was
it was the the amazingness of it is that
due to due to cell phone technologies
and
and social media it was almost spread
around
and i have to wonder did the arab spring
fail
when i when you still read about
conflicts in egypt
and libya and syria and you realize wow
a lot of these countries that went
through this arab spring it's not
this didn't get over the hump but i
wonder again is it
does does it come down to an individual
a hero a
figurehead albeit perhaps is that's
is that a is that a a lever in in so
social justice so that's something
actually that there's been a lot of talk
about
in in uh sort of radical left circles
particularly what the occupied arab
spring
and stuff like that and they talk about
these leaderless
movements um some of them like the
zapatistas have been very successful
they've managed to actually continue on
but a lot of them are very ephemeral and
andy and i were at a lecture by by this
guy
michael hart was thinking a lot about
these these sort of things and his
his line was well you know maybe we
don't really need leadership
you know this sort of thing is going to
work itself we're in a new paradigm
and i was listening and i was like yeah
i don't think so he was very interested
in what sort of militated against
leadership
because there's kind of there's kind of
this um alert allergy to leadership
because it sounds very hierarchical and
all that
but the nice thing about leadership is
not just that you have a figurehead
but that you actually have some coherent
direction
somebody to actually take responsibility
and say we're going this way
uh and and you're you're able to have
continuity and
i think that without without you don't
necessarily need to have like a top
you know guy or girl or however it's
going to be
running things but you do need to have
like some some top people
who maybe that maybe aren't super
recognizable outside of whatever
movement
but within the movement they they
command respect they people actually
think that they
they're on the ball you know what
they're doing but those people aren't
always benevolent
and well you know it's a whole different
sometimes sometimes you could argue that
you need a martyr
right it can't just be a person but it's
got to be someone who sacrifices yeah
um but i do yeah you just want to i mean
it's very
uh interesting just to do it you should
have the last word because
chris you brought a very open like a new
discussion that could take another 30
minutes
i think it's it's a very interesting the
way you brought
you you put ferguson and yeah and uh
i've done shoot to your decorate the
arab spring
and your individual but i mean it's it's
it's amazing
thing umbrella that you brought together
and i think the
the idea or the uh the the answer
to what you are saying comes i mean wrap
up to
the vision around uh it's the general
truth
you know that that mindless i don't know
how do i
analyze it i mean to wrap it up in a
nutshell i think it's uh it's about
the individual conviction i think that
the way it is
and it's beautiful when you say i i
didn't feel like joining this mass
because it's more external i mean i can
be one more person into it what does it
change
why did it fade away so quick arab swing
is gone
hands up don't shoot is gone right it's
like gone
what about wall street what is it
right those are like movement that would
be change is coming but then they fade
away
what is it because the individual right
because there is something in the
individual
that need to change right yeah let's
just wrap it there
it's something in the individual it
comes from inside
and we have it martin luther king is not
just one right
jesus was not just one it's inside us
but how far do we go
to to to to stimulate it to bring it to
to rise and to make you the champion
that leader everybody is a leader
you stop that because that's so
inspiring to say but we have to continue
that conversation
that's a great question
yeah i'm interested okay okay well i go
ahead
and thank you thank you to everyone for
being here and obviously to to greg and
abdu it's been fascinating
and we look forward to many more
conversations